armored cavalry units of the 25th
Infantry Division sweep across dry rice
paddies near Khushi on 8 April to begin
a recovery operation during a Search and
Destroy mission on the previous day as
Operation Kahuku a routine one-day
action began the Vietcong shot down a
you h1b helicopter the Huey which was
being used for observation burst into
flames and exploded upon impact all five
persons aboard escaped however two with
second-degree burns and the other three
with minor scratches the wreckage is
being recovered to prevent the VC from
using the metal as shrapnel in their
handmade bombs and booby traps on the
following day 9 April elements of the
25th converge on the Michelin rubber
plantation some six kilometers northwest
of Khushi intelligence from a captured
VC indicates that a unit of Vietcong are
holed up nearby in the armored unit soon
make contact with the enemy
the Vietcong caught off guard in their
complex of trenches and spider holes
opened fire on the u.s. elements with
automatic weapons grenades and mortars
while one u.s. platoon returns the fire
to more close in from both flanks and
quickly overrun the objective before
searching the VC bunkers and caves the
US troops raked their entrances with
short bursts from m16 then the
infantryman enter the maze of trenches
and begin removing the Vietcong dead by
actual body count on the battlefield
this unit of the 25th killed 11 of the
enemy and inflicted an unknown number of
additional casualties also according to
a forward observer with the unit about
30 Vietcong escaped the trap and
led toward the Cambodian border the FO
called for artillery fire which
according to his eyewitness report cut
down many of the retreating communists
US casualties consisted of three minor
fragmentation wounds with no personnel
killed in action so hasty was the Viet
congs retreat that they left behind food
ready for cooking and their supply of
tobacco captured weapons and equipment
included a 57-millimeter recoilless
rifle round - 7 machineguns - automatic
rifles 1 anti-tank gun more than 50
grenades and considerable ammo much of
the material was made in communist China
after the objective is cleared and
declared secure the unit begins to
reorganize within three hours after
initial contact with a VC other elements
of the 25th arrived to link up with the
lead company and pursue the fleeing
communist
while airstrikes are being made against
the retreating Vietcong
ammunition is redistributed from the
newly committed unit then they are ready
to continue the sweep
during this advance one of the armored
personnel carriers pushing through
jungle vines hit a 15-foot ditch
overturned and caught fire while some
members of the unit begin operations to
recover the personnel carrier others
extinguish the small fire in the engine
compartment meanwhile equipment and
ammunition are removed from the trapped
vehicle after the APC was retrieved the
units pushed ahead there was no further
contact with a VC however and a day's
end the troops returned to their base
camp
that's laughing gah 70 kilometers
southeast of Saigon a howitzer battery
supports units of the 1st Infantry
Division it is 7 April and operation
Abilene is still underway at a rubber
plantation nearby an NCO conducts a
class on patrolling for administrative
personnel of a headquarters battery the
intent is to keep all men up to date on
basic infantry tactics regardless of
their primary assignments the class was
instituted by the new division commander
Major General William Edie Pugh who was
being briefed here at a forward CP on
operational plans meanwhile a company
commander briefs his men on their
mission for the night the unit will
march to upon fool a village ten
kilometres to the southwest where the VC
are reported to be holding prisoners
before sending them north before dawn
the following morning 8th April the
patrol had surrounded the village and a
search party including interpreters
moved into upon food the village however
was deserted so the patrol and it's
supporting cavalry unit moved out to
join other brigade elements at a new
forward CP about three kilometers
northeast of zabinga at the new CP Viet
Cong prisoner is captured by other
elements of the big red one are
interrogated one of them makes a tape
recording for psychological warfare
operations the captive says he has been
well treated by the Americans wishes he
had given up earlier and urges his
friends to surrender the tape will be
played in the area from a helicopter on
the next day 9 April the unit's made a
3-hour march to an area ten kilometres
distant where a new base camp and
forward CP were set up from here the
units continued their probes and sweeps
the monsoon season will convert these
clouds of dust into rivers of mud within
a few weeks
later on the same day 9 April another
unit of the first infantry was filmed as
it searched zoms UNAM a small village
nearby for Vietcong after armored
personnel carriers surrounded the
village a search party of squad strength
and two interpreters began a hospital's
check of the residents also the many
bunkers and other hiding places are
thoroughly searched and the occupants
removed and questioned with the aid of
the interpreters the troops check the
identification papers of all male
vietnamese adults within a few minutes
after the unit entered the village the
search pays off one Vietcong is
discovered and hustled off to the
waiting personnel carriers the communist
guerrilla is bound and blindfolded
before being transported back to the
base camp here the prisoners will be
interrogated as of 10 April 23 enemy
were reported killed 15 captured and
more than 650 suspects detained during
operation Abilene
caribou aircraft deliver 175 millimeter
ammunition to artillery units supporting
operation Lincoln on 5 April the drop
zone is located approximately 16
kilometers north of pleiku ammunition in
the resupply weighs several thousand
pounds artillerymen break open the
special packing and remove the
waterproof covering encasing the big
projectiles the contents are in good
condition and the delivery is a success
the ammunition will be used to support a
suite in the two-prong mountain area by
troops of the 1st Cavalry Division air
mobile elements of the 25th Infantry
Division are also taking part in
operation Lincoln resupply of additional
items for the artillery batteries is
accomplished by helicopter here an empty
water tank trailer is taken away
meanwhile helicopters take off from
their base at unque and fly to pick up
the assault troops and transport them to
the objective area during the 10 days
since the operation began 368 Vietcong
have been killed fighting during the
period took place in the area between
Pleiku and the Cambodian border
five US helicopters had been downed by
enemy ground fire but three were
recovered for repair now in this final
sweep of the Chuang mountain area the
clearing operation continues with the
air mobile soldiers aboard the assault
choppers head for an LZ situated
northwest to play ku and about 300
meters from the Cambodian border as the
Huey's touched down the troopers move
across the LZ clearing and into the
woods following a sweep of the area with
negative results the men are ordered out
soon afterward the assault forces
airborne heading for another LZ 10
kilometers away 16 kilometers northeast
to Pleiku the first wave of helicopters
settles to earth at landing zone oasis
and the men debark with the Vietcong
apparently out of the area their next
mission is being planned as Operation
Lincoln continues
shortly after midnight on 13 April the
Vietcong launched a mortar attack on
Thompson at air base at Saigon a fuel
tank was set afire by one of the 50
mortar rounds lobbed into the air base
during the attack which lasted 20
minutes in the midst of the extensive
damage the immediate problem is control
of the fire Vietnamese and Air Force
firemen spray water on nearby fuel tanks
to prevent further spreading of the
flames
five Americans and 14 Vietnamese were
killed during the attack fifty Americans
were wounded and many aircraft were
damaged by the bursts the condition of
this uh-1b is typical of the extent of
damage to individual craft
in all thirty-one aircraft were hit by
the VC this c-123 with tail damage and
underside shrapnel holes also had its
side ripped out the c-47 was almost
completely demolished
however sandbag emplacements around
other aircraft considerably reduced
damage
- this m79 grenade launcher the grenade
site for the m1 rifle has been attached
by a 173rd airborne member as a field
expedient this allows grenadiers is to
use higher trajectory for accurate
indirect fire
elements of the US Army engineers
arrived in the sutta Heep area of
Thailand on 15 february after completing
construction work on the Bangkok bypass
road after two months the company is
deep into its twofold mission one part
is the preparation of a military housing
complex to include more than a hundred
structures whole sections of wall
structures are raised in one piece and
fastened to the floor mass production
techniques used in large housing
projects are utilized here a new town on
the Thailand Plains is rapidly nearing
completion the other and more vital part
of the mission is the construction
nearby of base pads and foundations for
a tank farm for the storage of petroleum
oil and lubricants both projects are
located approximately three kilometres
from the Gulf of Siam and 192 kilometers
southeast of Bangkok here freshly mixed
concrete is poured into a bucket loader
under the supervision of an engineer
sergeant the loader then transports the
mix to a prepared form where a
foundation for fuel pumps is being
constructed
the tank farm construction will include
five 10,000 barrel vaulted steel storage
tanks more than 200 Thai civilians
supplement the working force
the farm will store JP for aircraft fuel
for an airstrip to be constructed in the
area a pol pipeline will join the tank
farm to the airfield the target date for
completion of this project is June 25th
of this year
some 15 kilometers west of pleiku at a
tea plantation a civic action team holds
sick call on 9 April with the aid of an
Arvind interpreter a medical team visits
two villages a day examining patients
and prescribing medication
these men examining local workers and
their families are attached to a civil
affairs company of the first Air Cav
division the medics jobs are complicated
by the large turnover of destitute
patients some of them pretend illness
while others who are really ill refused
to follow the prescription given for
Vietnamese children under 15 years of
age the death rate from disease has been
almost five times that of children in
the u.s. malaria tuberculosis dysentery
typhoid and dietary deficiencies are
traditionally the leading causes of
illness and death here
an army signal brigade is activated at
Camp Gayler near tunson at Air Force
Base Brigadier General Richard J Seitz
deputy chief of staff
US Army Vietnam attends the ceremonies
the activation and awards and
decorations presentation take place on 6
April this unit is called the US Army
strategic communications signal brigade
Southeast Asia
it contains all non-organic signal units
in Vietnam the brigade is under
operational control of US Army Vietnam
general sites presents the brigade
colors to the brigade commander colonel
robert d terry to conclude the
ceremonies
in the Dominican Republic Easter Sunday
is celebrated at services held in this
civilian Catholic Church located in the
modern Fairgrounds American soldiers
stationed nearby join the many local
citizens attending the mass also on this
Easter Sunday the traditional sunrise
services are held for Protestant
military personnel this service is
taking place at Camp Randall
on the following day 11 April a farewell
review is held in Santo Domingo for
Ambassador W Tapley Bennett jr. who is
leading the Dominican Republic on the
completion of his assignment there the
ambassador and Brigadier General Robert
R Linville commander US forces Dominican
Republic troop the line the men are
mostly from the 82nd Airborne Division
with various other elements attached the
440th Army Band leads the review at Camp
Randall a flyover is performed by uh-1b
helicopters then the troops pass and
review in this farewell parade -
ambassador bennett who represented the
united states during the period of
crisis in santo domingo
you